- Hi, my name's Awkwafina and fuck.
Hi, my name's Awkwafina,
star of "The Farewell", um fuck.
Hi, my name's Awkwafina
star of "The Farewell",
a movie about fuck.
Hi, fuck.
I'm a great actress obviously.
I do great line reads.
Hi, my name's Awkwafina
star of "The Farewell",
a story about grandmas
and these are my favorite
movies that I like to
watch with my grandma.
(foreign language)
My relationship with my grandma,
I mean, she is my, she's my Ride or Die,
she's my BFF,
she gives me everything from
love to financial advice,
and she believes in me.
Movies fit into my
relationship with my grandma
because it was way that I
could understand her humor.
I couldn't understand the
Chinese movies she would put on
and plus, they were all
very, like unnecessary,
you know what I mean,
like I think I was watching
one where this ghost,
he was like a child, a
ghost-child comes out,
he's like, "Wait, there's more."
and 15 other ghost children come out.
So I was like, "I don't think
I could watch this right now."
The types of movies that my grandma liked
were literally only movies
starring Kenan and Kel,
Matin Lawrence, and or "Forensic Files".
My earliest movie memory that
I would watch with my grandma,
possibly "Good Burger".
- Welcome to Good Burger,
home of the Good Burger.
Can I take your order?
- She loved Kenan and Kel.
She thought Kel was like, the best.
And then I was on "Saturday
Night Live" and I told her that
I met Kenan, and it was like the only time
that she was starstruck.
My God, she was like,
"Wah, what's he like?"
And I was like, "He's great man."
So one movie that my
grandma watched incessantly,
to the point where we actually
bought it for her on Blu-ray
is a lovely film called "Blue Streak",
in which Martin Lawrence
teams up with Luke Wilson
to recover some diamonds
that he hid in the ceiling.
But this was before, you know, he was,
he went to prison for a
while, then he comes out,
come to find the diamonds are
in the ceiling of a precinct,
so that, uh-oh, right?
My grandma loved that movie.
We watched it all the time, incessantly.
She can probably quote
it, she loved Martin.
That was her man,
and what else was there?
Oh, "My Cousin Vinny",
I haven't watched, she
loved "My Cousin Vinny",
my grandma loves "My Cousin Vinny".
I believe that my grandma
actually told me to watch
"My Cousin Vinny" for the first
time when I was really young
or my dad had a VHS of it,
and they would talk about it all the time,
and I never understood who Vinny was,
like they would always talk
about "My Cousin Vinny"
and then so finally like,
they showed it to me
and my grandma was very
tickled by Joe Pesci,
she like loves Joe,
like even when I would watch "Home Alone",
which is one of my favorite movies,
she'd be like, "Oh, my cousin Vinny."
His name's Joe Pesci, yah well.
She liked "Babe", the one with the pig.
I personally was not a fan of "Babe",
especially not, when he
was a pig in the city.
- That looks stupid mom.
- Not as stupid as sheep, mind you
but pigs are definitely stupid.
- Ahem.
Excuse me, no we're not.
I've forced my grandma
to watch tons of movies,
"Ocean's 8", "Crazy Rich
Asians", "Dude" on Netflix,
"The Farewell", I gotta screener.
My grandma has seen "The Farewell".
I basically signed onto
"The Farewell" as kind of,
cause I love my grandma so
much and I wanted to do this,
and I was so happy.
I asked the studio for a screener,
"Please give me one screener,
"I'll just give it to my grandma."
Gave me a screener,
we like sat down to watch it,
and right at the part
where after the wedding,
like when I'm about to, like the end,
my grandma gets up,
she gets up,
and she goes, "I gotta start cooking."
Can you believe that?
I was like pivotal,
she said her butt hurt.
Stand!
My God.
My grandma's favorite
movie that I've been in,
I would have to say,
either "Ocean's 8" or "Crazy Rich Asians"
but I think "Ocean's 8"
because she keeps telling me,
she's like, "What's that
girl's name, so funny."
and I'm like, "Sarah Paulson",
and she's like, "Yeah, I love her."
- Wait, wait,
every time you move it--
- Sometimes you just have--
- you have to
- to gently...
- start from scratch.
- What did you do?
- What'd she do?
- I turned it on.
- Oh.
- A least favorite of my movies...
- [Interviewer] Or
anything that you've done?
- Probably the movie that I
have a masturbation scene in.
I don't know if she enjoyed that.
- [Interviewer] Which is...?
- (laughs) All of them.
Um (laughs), "Dude"
but I think that, I actually
think that my grandma
watched "Dude" in which I
had a masturbation scene,
and she watched the masturbation scene,
and didn't realize what I was doin',
so, that's on me. (laughs)